nicht nur der weltraum sondern auch die
tiefen unserer ozeane sind noch
weitestgehend unerforscht doch es werden
immer mehr high tech geräte entwickelt
die auch in vielen tausend metern tiefe
funktionieren beispielsweise im
südpazifik konkret im sogenannten
atacama graben rund 150 kilometer von
der küste chiles und perus entfernt in
unfassbaren 8000 metern tiefe herrschen
extremer druck und eisige kälte
eigentlich keine guten bedingungen für
leben doch jetzt hat ein britisches
forschungsteam genau dort eine
geisterhafte entdeckung gemacht und
spannende details zum leben an dem
tiefsten orten der erde gewonnen
herzlich willkommen bei pixum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal damit
er nichts verpasst er ist lang und ich
seine haut ist durchsichtig und seine
bewegungen sind geschmeidig die rede ist
vom sogenannten schnecken fisch drei
bislang noch unbekannte arten dieses
fisches konnte ein forschungsteam aus
newcastle jetzt im atacama graben
aufspüren quasi aliens hier auf der erde
denn diese lebewesen waren bisher
unbekannt einer der tiefsten orte der
erde überhaupt und die filmaufnahmen
dieser bisher unbekannten arten in blau
lila und pink sind wirklich einzigartig
der lebensraum der tiere ist der tiefsee
grund genau genommen in einer tiefe von
6400 metern und die lebensbedingungen da
unten sind extrem es herrscht nicht nur
ein extremer druck sondern auch extreme
kälte doch nicht nur das eines der
exemplare konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sogar bergen zwar im toten zustand aber
immerhin das ermöglicht es dem team
jetzt den fisch im labor genauer unter
die lupe zu nehmen doch jetzt steht
schon fest dass sich die tiere optimal
an die extremen lebensbedingungen in der
tiefsee angepasst haben dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher thomas lynley
richtige struktur macht es ihnen möglich
sich perfekt an den extremen druck
anzupassen da ihr körper sehr
empfindlich ist würden die tiere sogar
ohne den druck und die kälte sterben ja
tatsächlich sie würden bei wärmeren
temperaturen sogar schmelzen des
forschungsteams sind die knochen in
ihren edlen ohren die härtesten
strukturen in ihrem ganzen körper
kurioserweise entsprechen die schnecken
fische nun mal sogar
dem klischee der tiefseefische die man
im kopf haben könnte denn er ist weder
besonders imposant noch hat der schuppen
oder gar große zähne dennoch scheint es
den fischen sehr gut in dieser extremen
tiefe zu gehen denn sie befinden sich
außerhalb der reichweite von anderen
fischen und haben somit keine
konkurrenten futter dagegen gibt es
reichlich
auch das ist eine erkenntnis die das
britische forschungsteam bei der
exkursion in 6500 metern tiefe gewinnen
konnte manche bereiche in dieser region
sind übrigens bis zu 11.000 meter tief
und genau deswegen sind diese gebiete
weitestgehend es auch immer noch
unerforscht das high-tech-gerät der
britischen universität war auf eine art
länder befestigt worden mit hd kameras
und fallen ausgestattet dann dauerte es
einige stunden bis das gerät auf den
meeresboden gesunken ist dann konnten
videoaufnahmen gemacht werden und proben
gesammelt werden bei der letzten
expedition des britischen
forschungsteams entstanden mehr als 100
stunden videomaterial und knapp 11.500
fotos und der schnecken fisch war nicht
die einzige überraschung die die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dadurch zu gesicht bekamen seltene
aufnahmen entstanden auch von
langweiligen asseln die in etwa so groß
sind wie eine erwachsene hand mit
kleinem körper aber extrem langen beinen
die tiere schwimmen rückwärts dann
richten sie sich am meeresboden auf und
breiten ihre langen beine aus wie eine
spinne dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher
es ist unglaublich sie in ihrem
natürlichen lebensraum in aktion zu
sehen besonders toll ist der mist den
sie machen wenn sie vom schwimmen zum
gehen wechseln wenn ihr wirklich kein
video zu unseren spannenden themen
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auch den
englischen kanal klicks um
science-fiction hier einfach
draufklicken da gibt es die eine oder
andere video premiere und ihr könnt mit
mir euer englisch verbessern oder es
euren englischen freunden und
freundinnen empfehlen und darunter geht
es auch direkt weiter also dafür auch
draufklicken frankensteins health
research unit hybrid bus ja viel spaß
damit und bis dann bleibt dran